i can start right now you guys ready
yeah yep another shin hit
it this is how we do it this is how we
do
it this is how we do it
how was uh tempe boys it was great uh
did you guys miss me
we did it sucks and you guys have fun on
the road then i'm
at home in my underwear did you just
brought brenda
that's cool he was like yo did malik
bring any dudes to the green room yet
a whole lot of dudes yeah it was a good
time though yeah it was good man
crazy so was that saturday
no tell them what you wait tell them
what you did in the group chat didn't
tell them what happened so
you know green room etiquette don't take
a dump
in the green room bathroom right comedy
one-on-one
he did that you took a sh headliner i
threw it in the group
in the group chat right saturday
i'm on stage right all of a sudden i
start getting sweats
and my stomach just did you eat
something weird
bruh we i got food poisoning from jt's
i don't i don't know if it was jc's i
don't know
i don't know i don't think it was like
subway some [ __ ]
no i ate i hate really bad we ain't like
horrible hey wendy's
oh it's 90s so say no and then what a
burger
i said i i ended my night with
whataburger right yeah keeping the
lettuce on the water burger oh my god
dude it was it was i had to see you're
on stage on stage and all of a sudden
i'm like sweating i'm like bro like
what's that
it was he had the hoodie on oh i had my
hoodie on
i put the microphone down in the middle
of my set wait what do you think i said
water here what the hell
i put the mic on the stove hold on
everybody
i threw the sweater because i was just
like burning up and i was like man i got
it
i got to get through this set it was
like the middle of the set and so
uh my stomach's just like going at it
right yeah
and the the checks get dropped right i
saw i was like okay
checks are dropped yeah once the checks
are dropped you're kind of good to kind
of yeah
that's all they want so i was like okay
let me just let them get through this
check part yeah and then i'm gonna get
the [ __ ] off we're gonna have to close
it soon as soon as people started
signing their tips that's my time good
night that's my time tonight
michael turner runs up he's like you
okay i said i do not feel well
i ran off stage ran to the green room
bathroom
i was what like 20 minutes blowing it up
that's not it come on continue i flooded
the toilet
i messed the whole bathroom up that's
the whole bathroom that's how a good
friend i am i didn't say anything how
did you flood it
was it the toilet so usually the toilet
paper does it no yeah probably but i
don't know
and the water started coming out water
started oh that was such a crazy feeling
oh my god i see that water right no no
no no no no that's it when they said
because i i was already done i was out
and i was just sitting sitting there
and when they said yo the
toilet's flooding and the water is just
like right it was on the floor
the dookie water man's dookie water
here's the thing
i had to go tell them to talk about this
yeah plumber came last night funny thing
about the plumber
he was a fan yeah he was like yo like
cool man
that is
[Laughter]
it was oh my gosh like they they had to
uh give me
apple cider vinegar yeah i could take it
and then but you know it's food
poisoning because it went away like
the next day or good the next yeah so
like my stomach was good but like you
know like
you still have that kind of like like uh
you're not drunk but you're still
hungover yeah that's like the feeling
like
your stomach is still you want to yeah
let's just talk about what you're doing
so like what did you say
about your diet how long are we in
pretending
because i get a picture eating cinnabon
i got it right here
they follow me on social media yeah yeah
you eating cinnabon
i got a picture you eating cinnabon on
the way to tempe from him
uh can we pull this up chin yeah so
let's just go over what you've eaten
this weekend
cinnabun we know whataburger wendy's
yeah
jt wings what else malik uh he also had
he went out to lunch with someone his
family i don't know oh yeah
yeah where'd you go some like bar grill
what'd you have i had a uh then he had a
nerve enough
like don't say salad oh relationships
yeah like yeah then at the end of the
weekend he's ordering like uh
food like uh but he's eating healthy the
korean the korean fried rice
it doesn't matter it doesn't matter and
also like getting fried
you think that's gonna weigh out all the
[ __ ] that i ate also korean fried rice
ain't healthy it's like spoiled sugar
butter yeah he made a smart choice to
create fries
yeah i know but i appreciate you helping
appreciate it he had a salad on the last
one i did yeah
yeah oh i couldn't even eat that salad
you didn't mm-hmm
it was tough oh yeah yeah cause it
doesn't taste like jt dude yeah i
i still like don't want to eat really
you know what i mean i don't know what
because i'm terrified you know well at
least she got like
like i haven't had food poisoning in a
while it's like so rough dude it's so
rough and it just like
oh it knocks your [ __ ] body out dude
but like so okay so this show on
saturday that was
this was early show when i [ __ ] when
it hit okay so late show
i could have saved shout out to [ __ ]
chad at tempe improv for being so great
i was like who's chad he's the general
uh the general manager he runs
the club up there and uh he uh so i was
like yo
is it okay like they they were very
understanding because they they saw the
aftermath
i was like i was like i'll hit a solid
30 for you
you know what i mean would you stop
mouthing so i just said yeah i just had
white mike two more times
yeah i just had them do more time look
at my mate i mean yeah they're fine on
the time as long as you
yeah yeah yeah and it was perfect like
the show ran
so smooth like dude look at you saying
you didn't have cinnabon
i see everything [ __ ] hold on bro
photoshop
like bedroom wise right now yeah
photoshop's a big can i take you into
this can't take it inside the car one
time all right so we had
wendy's and we stopped and the wendy's
is in the gas station right
but in the gas station they have
cinnabun hell yeah and chappelle's like
we need to fill up
so i was like okay cool he was like bro
what's up with that cinema cinnabun
yeah i was like what you mean i mean
looking at me i said okay cool you want
one i was like yeah yeah give me one dog
so i go in there use the restroom get
two cinnamon buns all right
get out he eats wendy's right now
afterwards i'm still on my sandwich
he looks like bro what's up with that
cinnamon bun i said bro we driving
you driving right now yeah he was like
bro i don't care it's too fresh
then he goes malik cut it up for me so
cause i can't drive and cut at the same
time oh yeah i tried to tell him to cut
it up
i said what the [ __ ] up and feed him so
you know what i did
that [ __ ] it just took the whole thing
and just started yeah yeah like a
doughnut dog
i was like how long are you going to
pretend that you're not am i going to
pretend
bruh yeah i ate like [ __ ] who's audi is
that
i rented it oh dope yeah it was nice
oh yeah we had a jam session too me and
uh chappelle probably gonna start oh
yeah we
yeah i post that i have some what about
one of my boys shout out to tim
kirch we were up in his studio yeah um
jamming the [ __ ] out check my man out
come on
but you got to see malik's freestyle oh
i had bars
where was that at where's your first
time on my page yeah the freestyle is on
his page oh damn
papa chappelle came through came through
right there look at that too yeah
styling
look at that yeah that's that's he's got
that uh jeep
gladiator he has the gladiator killing
it too he's killing it
he was giving me peace he was
yeah he's such an og man look at him
damn that right is dope yeah yeah
got his merch on the wall with the
crenshaw hoodie yeah
put it right there in the front of the
club they pulled right in front of the
club
funny because no one messed with the
club knew exactly like
that he was my dad they were like oh
that's true yeah
oh yeah watch my look get it bars look
at jelly roll shout out to jelly roll
check this out look
i always wanted the best i got a lot
oh off the top by the way they don't
believe me though
they think i'm sleazy bro check me out
look i like to go in i got a lot of
weekends i got a lot of shows and i got
a lot of flow
i got a lot of girls that be pulling off
the clothes come on bro
i'm ripping it bro i'm ripping it she
always thought i wasn't close
i swear to god that i am [ __ ] come on
little brows put big bars
yeah man we're in the track rolly boy
we're going to drop the big shine dish
next
how was your uh how was your
thanksgiving let's take a little break
from the shenanigans few housekeeping
notes for you listen
the gems may not be full because
everybody's scared of that covid but
there's no shortage of
madness this college basketball season
forest fans the college basketball
powers that be
have gifted us with the top matchups
between two
powerhouses this weekend gonzaga baylor
will be going toe to toe for what could
be
the nation's top ranking game draftking
sportsbook america's top rated
sportsbook app is bringing you closer
to the action with these can't miss
offers draftking sportsbook has given
all college basketball fans who sign up
right now
the chance to win 100 when betting on
either gonzaga
or baylor to win this clash of the
titans plus
your deposit bonus up to 1 000 when
you're signing up
using the promo code fighter draftking
sportsbook has endless ways for you to
bet
there's boxing this weekend there's ufc
there's nfl
there's freaking college basketball you
got all sorts of ways
to make your money place your bets
draftkings is safe reliable and secure
making it easy for you to deposit and
withdraw your money at your convenience
download the top-rated draft book
sportsbook app
now use the promo code fighter when you
sign up for your shot to turn one
dollar into 100 when betting on either
gonzaga or baylor to win that's right
one dollar to win 100 on gonzaga versus
baylor
use promo code fighter during the sign
up to take advantage of these offers for
limited time only at draftkings
sportsbook
must be 21 or older new jersey indiana
pennsylvania only
bonus comprised the first deposit bonus
deposit bonus requires 25 times
playthrough
restrictions supply c drivekings.com
sportsbook for details gambling problem
cool call 1800 gambler or in indiana
1-809
with it again that's freaking
draftking sportsbook app download it use
the promo code fighter
everybody getting sick man you need your
fluids maybe you did a lot of drinking
over the weekend maybe
you're doing a show in boise and you're
hungover from the local whiskey whatever
it is you need to get hydrated
you need to get liquid iv one stick of
liquid iv and 16 ounces of water gets
you two to three
times the amount of hydration as plain
water what are you doing man
flu season often lines up with the
holiday plants but liquid iv can help
you support your immune system
and increase your hydration with
essential vitamins it's perfect for
staying hydrated on the holiday flights
the long road trips we got you
handled man hangovers after
all the holiday stuff liquid iv is gonna
be your best
friend tasty flavors it's delicious i
love the watermelon myself
i put it in there i feel great you got
essential vitamins
you got three delicious new flavors all
right you got chris watermelon my
personal favorite
apple pie juicy guava whatever you want
we got you covered man
what makes liquid iv so effective well
how about again one stick of liquid i
mean 16 ounces of water
can give you as much hydration as two to
three bottles of plain water
quit drinking all that water get liquid
iv right now liquid iv is available
nationwide at walmart
in the beverage section or you get 25
off when you go to liquidive.com
use the code fighter at checkout that's
25 off
anything when you order use the promo
code fighter liquidity.com
get better hydration today at
liquidity.com promo code fighter
how was your uh how was your
thanksgiving i haven't seen you since
thanksgiving oh we haven't um
thanksgiving thanksgiving with the uh
the girl
and her parents was first time meeting
the parents first time being a parent i
get nervous fast
so i don't like i don't i'm not great at
meeting people that's why you're a nice
guy
what are you nervous about well because
i mean it's the parents it's a different
look so
has she dated a black guy before do you
know i don't no no no was it a get out
situation
it wasn't a ghetto well kind of what was
that this small table
right it's me her and her cousin and
they're all like sharing stories i'm the
only black guy there
right i just want to clarify that so i
get i show up late because i i
won't stop
so i can't
can i get that let me get that let me
get through my stuff
do it man all right
so earlier earlier i'm with my i'm with
the
black family i'm eating good food i was
like okay oh you're with your family
exactly okay cool so i was like i'm
gonna spend thanksgiving
night with her family so i get over
there they're already
drinking and i get in late uh like hey
what's up babe she's like oh my god
her mom is on the phone so she's in the
kitchen cooking i was like yeah okay i'm
gonna go to the restroom
right and it was a weird interaction
where i'm in a restroom and her mom
walks
in so oh hey how are you your piano
taking a [ __ ]
no i was kidding okay number one not
chappelle right oh so yeah
100 so i'm i'm peeing and she's oh i
don't know if she saw my piece but
if she did i mean what's up she was nice
afterwards because i
i hope she saw her she's always awkward
though it was awkward a little bit you
know so what was she like was she like
well i saw she was oh my god i was like
oh i didn't know and then yeah it was a
little
little little threesome yeah and her mom
can get it
i'm lit dude [ __ ] brandon
never mind god did it was awful i didn't
i didn't it was rough it was rough
because they were sharing stories i'm
saying
stories you're not involved in no and my
girl gets mad because
what were the stories just give me the
what was the premises
it's so boring a small town in ohio
and they was talking about like this
like oh my god you remember when
you used to like jump over the fish i'm
like oh and i don't know the worst
i was like yo she was like so molly tell
me about yourself well i don't have any
like dumb stories like that
yeah and i i didn't say it but i was
like y'all have any good stories
and then it was like i look standoffish
yeah i leave and then you think you're
an [ __ ]
and then your girl was like what the
[ __ ] yeah she was like i thought you
cool you were on your phone
well i was texting my friends i was 16
y'all and she was like oh my god you're
so rude we got to like this big argument
i was like hold on
relax let's think about what we have in
hand we got love love
always what is love love is time love is
gangster so i had to remember he didn't
sound very loving at that house though
well brady we made it up oh you're cool
now we're cool enough yeah yeah yeah
that is tough man how was your
thanksgiving i saw
chappelle with the pie in his head yep
chappelle ate a lot of food
first of all we all did but then
he threw it on me though as if he didn't
eat any
any food as well you ate a lot of food
and then we send you home with a plate
for your girl
oh what happened i don't the group i was
like
how long we gonna pretend that i'm gonna
wait for my girlfriend to eat this
did she not get any of it no
[Laughter]
oh she got some of the pie oh god i
couldn't wait dog i was like
how was your son birthday uh brenden it
was cool with you bro he had a
setup talk to me they had like uh i
don't know what the hell you call that
thing like a little
it was like a little uh theo says
shawty looking back
what was it brendan that it was like a
play center for they come they come and
set it up so it's like
made for like toddlers so they're like
oh you don't keep that in your house
no [ __ ] no oh you got rid of it yeah
they just set that up for the day and
then take it down
oh damn it's dope though it's like a
little play area for you know switch
during coven
yeah so it's like a playpen and all that
[ __ ] damn
oh chappelle had to kick dude out this
show last night oh never seen chappelle
kick something happen
he just wouldn't stop talking what was
he was he like a cool talk you know the
no he was gonna get him dog
or he's like talking no he was he was
trying he was doing it to him too what
was he doing he was just trying to have
a conversation with him like while he
was doing his jokes
he was there by himself getting
on the table yeah and he's a fan of the
white black guy white white guy
he's a super he was what was he yelling
out with during your set oh so i'll get
to the jokes and he was like man i love
you man you killing them
yeah or whatever so then he kept doing
it then we're like do it dog you gotta
get it yeah i was like you know what
well the guy the security guy i was like
because i was you know i lied to rose
so i just said how come how come because
you if they're doing dude you're set
yeah and i hear it i'll be like i'll
tell the manager like hey dude
give him one morning keeps going get him
out yeah yeah yeah yeah i didn't i
didn't i didn't know
he was don't make me do it during my set
because he's gonna [ __ ] up the rhythm
i told him i was like bro calm down
enjoy the show and then the security
guard i was like no don't kick him out
just like calm down
are you good he's all right i respect
you know and all that oh god
see that's the problem yeah i told him
he was he did something like i was like
you know like just whatever you know
handle them whatever
but he just kept saying sorry and i was
like like
loud yeah just drunk i bet i bet she's
listening to this right now being like
[ __ ] yeah yeah that's the bummer you
know and it's not like it's not like
like if he came up to me i wouldn't like
hate the dude but it's just like you
can't be in here right now you just got
sober up well you're [ __ ] up the
expense for everybody yeah that's and
that's how i
that's how i explain it to people like
you're the one dude in phoenix
stevo garbo oh yeah and then he's
walking through i'm like
i started clowning him yeah and then he
started like coming to the stage and i
hear
his girl go he's a ufc fighter
yeah and uh oh over here in phoenix and
also it was a dude's
almost fought in tippi improv
like so it was the second show next and
arizona but they love chapelle but it
was like you got a lot of latinos coming
out to see
yeah yeah okay so yeah so
they the this first show was leaving the
second show
was like like coming upstairs yeah and
he was inside you know i like to talk to
people
so i was going out to get you like
something for your nose or something
like that
oh there's [ __ ] arizona dirt mess up
his sinuses yeah
as i'm going down yeah man i see like a
group so they was like what's up homie
what's up homie to you
no no no to each other cool i was like
hey bro if y'all gonna fight do it now
because i gotta hurry up and start the
second show
don't talk about it i know my man
brandon on there
they was like man what's up these what's
up and then it was like bro then there
was like comedy girls like calm down
come on
it's a good night we got free tickets i
was like hold on y'all ain't paid
someone probably bought them the tickets
huh no or they i think
like the club will do like a little push
so then it was like man calm down i was
like hold on hey bro you don't need to
do all that come on we're having a good
time
oh [ __ ] you're fighting the kids hello
hey what's up man what's up bro we hell
yeah we can you settle this
out yeah did you sell merch what should
you come up with you sell merch
i know such a shame i know i was
pretty sad about that but shout out to
this dude i was really impressed what
he did a great feature sets every night
thank you thank you bro because for
those that don't know the malik does a
lot of crazy
gifts crowd work so usually that's why
such a good opening there's a lot of
crowd work thank you but i told them
once especially when things start to
open up we're doing theaters can't do
crowd work in theaters nobody else can
see the crowd
because such a large audience they can't
see who you're referring to
so in a club you can do crowd work and
make fun of people everyone sees the
person or
you know and they have fun but in
theaters you can't because so you're
gonna be lighting somebody up and like
what the [ __ ] is he doing
yeah and she was like dude dude
yeah shout out he told me he texted me
sending great text
but yo man listen we're going to be
doing theater soon at crowd work you
know what i mean just start
like honing in and focusing on your
material i was like yo bro i listened to
my set
a hundred percent a lot of guys could
have took that the wrong way yeah yeah
yeah yeah
like nah but i was like yeah foreign for
us so i went out that whole week and
wrote
and he gave me thank you for 20 minutes
i'll talk to you about a little bit more
time
late after the show yeah and um
ten minutes i think anyways um so i
worked on it and chappelle like
he's like bro when i got off that first
show he was like god damn good set
yeah thank you i'm telling you man he's
got this closing bit i won't ruin it for
the audience because
he'll you'll see it appreciate it but
man he's got this closing bit
boys yeah saturday like every
like every time it went well boom no
thursday shows like phoenix
because you had friday saturdays well
our friday show was like
yeah but like but like still like it
like
you know he still ended it like yeah
very well and how did white mike do
white mike's great yep yeah yeah killed
it it was a great show thanks shout out
to everyone did you boys
uh watch the tyson uh i want to talk to
you about this tyson
oh uh he was on stage when it was going
on
when the main event when the main did
you see the rules though
that's what me okay yeah what was that
yeah
yeah it's strange because like all my
like peers
who do the same [ __ ] i do are all like
that was dope this is this this is this
and i'm below the belt my thing is like
how long are we pretending that that was
dope
yeah that was not dope that was some
[ __ ] it was cool that mike tyson got
in shape
but it was there's a gentleman's bet
there's no really hidden to the head
and that if it depends what frame of
mind you went into watching the fight so
let's say your dad who's not on social
media or anything one name was like dude
tyson about to rip roy a [ __ ]
you know he's gonna tear his hat off if
you're in that mind frame you'd be so
disappointed
because before this fight when this
fight got announced shortly after andy
foster who's the head of the california
commission went
this ain't a real fight yeah it's an
amateur fight there's bigger gloves
uh you know we give them a choice to
wear headgear there's gonna be no
knockouts no knockdowns
and they can't go too hard if they do
we're gonna intervene and make sure
they're not going too hard
really and then that got out and then
the neighbor was like [ __ ] this i'm not
buying this
and then that's when mike tyson roy
jones started coming out be like no no
no no we're gonna tear each other's head
off like this can be dope but we're
gonna do this this
i'm scared and they start releasing
these training videos really got the
public back into it
so then when you watch it and you don't
get a real fight and there's a draw it's
just like
it was a gentleman's bet it was like you
know how it is like
in boxing i'm sure like roy jones was
the perfect
candidate for mike tyson because he was
like take this fight you can get three
mil you'll probably get some back end
i mean 10 mil on some back and we're
both gonna make bank people tune into it
we'll put a big youtuber on it yeah
jake which we'll get to jake
and then you'll get money but i'm not
gonna knock you out i'm not going to hit
you the head i'm going to go to the body
you're cool with the body i'm cool with
the body
mike tyson comes in shape roy not in
shape oh kitties
whatever yes but it was just like you
know i i've called it from the jump man
and i'm not a
hater like i hope they make a ton of
money but it just ain't for me man like
yeah
it was just some [ __ ] like again how
long are we gonna pretend
that this [ __ ] is dope that wasn't dope
man
that wasn't cool it really pissed me off
and
uh you can jump in any time uh the two
minute rounds so two minute rounds
you take a minute off of of of like a
round
it's it's so significant because two
minutes you can spend one minute just
like okay trying to figure out
the last minute you can go hard then you
go back to your corner a minute rest
you like you re-energize it's not a real
fight that's women's boxing no
disrespect it's also an amateur boxing
amateur boxing golden gloves is two
minute rounds
yeah really but yeah but no i don't know
anything about it okay but i'm just
saying
let me play devil's advocate here and
this is where i was actually i thought
so the good things about the the take my
takeaway from it the production was dope
it's well lit
you know the way they the the camera
angle zoom dog coming out
we'll get this we'll get to snoopy we
will get to snoop a loop i didn't hear
below
get to snoop a little bit snoop lion is
what they call them snoop lion
um so the the production value was high
i dug all that but it was just
um so with the two minute rounds yeah to
me
boxing's like this the trend of boxing's
like this because the kids aren't into
it
because if you're let's say you're a 12
year old kid yeah my son right now he'll
be five in february
if i turn on the tv and i have him watch
earl spence
danny garcia to the best boxers on the
planet so dope yeah i can't wait either
we'll be on stage or whatever so dope
what we'll have in the green room okay
it's a great fight two of the best
incredible yes if you show that to kids
in
elementary school and then you show them
a ufc fight you show them any name any
big name
to connor versus dustin poiret not one
kid is going to tune in that boxing
match
it's just not exciting yeah and there's
12 rounds it's three minutes 12 rounds
they don't get started to round six
really yeah like they
like boxing the sweet science yeah they
warm up they figure each other out
it's like those first rounds are feeling
out process no one's really
throwing blows they take you know then
six through 12 it gets
hard so to me the eight uh
two minute rounds dog if they did that
like if earl spence and danny garcia did
that
you getting action-packed [ __ ] fights
if you only have that short amount of
time dudes are gonna throw dude
especially that heavyweight think of
heavyweight so you thinking this so you
think you should do it that way what
i think they should consider it yeah two
minute rounds have you ever
have you ever been watched a boxing
fight like
damn i wish there's 10 more rounds
me well i guess i'm wild or fury maybe
okay when he got knocked down
my only thing is as soon as boxing ends
i'm like thank god
unless there's like a javonte davis
fight where there's knockout yeah if
it's like
going like after 12 not once have i been
like goddamn oh sure is more rounds so
you texted me during the lomachenko and
lopez fight you said it was a great
fight
right if it weren't longer rounds would
you have been mad at it because it was
the action was starting to pick up i was
good
what i was good i was satisfied yeah
like there's there's it's very rare in
boxing like damn i wish there's more
okay but when there's like when you're
on the 10th now like [ __ ] thank god
there's only two left dog
certain fights it's a lot
they really don't start fighting till
six so it's kind of this weird like
they take it you know the feeling out
process yeah yeah
it's really them just you know not
blowing their wad not blowing their
mouths when you look at like floyd
connor like
you know he he just was taking rounds
off taking rounds off and then turn on
destroyed him yeah
but imagine if you went hey you're doing
you're doing four two minute
like floyd ain't feeling them out no you
know we would just get in there like
yeah what's up doug
it wouldn't be a different it would be
you know women's boxing is too many
rounds
bro i just thought you say you don't
feel like eating you said you literally
said that a couple minutes
don't know what you can always eat i
don't feel like you know but i can
always
but my thing is from that i was like
they went by fast i'm like man
you know it gave tyson a chance to kind
of get going a little bit there yeah
i don't know listen there's a lane for
it and it's all good and i hope they
make a ton of [ __ ] money
and i hope they can do it till they're
100 years old but it's it's just
you know for when i watched that main
event and i scrambled back over and
watched the main event the ufc
and it's just like dude come on it
depends what frame of mind you're in
okay because i watched so much fighting
i went in thinking even though i knew
the rules
i was like because i think maybe because
jake paul starts nate robinson
yeah so you're like damn this [ __ ] for
real yeah and then you know so you know
how long were there rounds three minutes
was it three
minutes three minute rounds uh because
that was a real fight yeah that was a
sanctuary
yeah yeah you got it that wasn't that
and i actually what do you think of nate
robinson starts you know he didn't know
sparring
i know which is stupid by the way and
you just i think it's good for the game
because you have so many celebrities
being like damn i'd love to bo
preacher we love preachers oh yeah we
love preaching a lot of people should
watch that i'm like
oh that's what could happen no no that's
what should happen
exactly if you don't train properly if
you don't have experience fight
again snoop said it was the best play
made all night
uh he made a lot of great points well he
made one great point
but um he can't play but he took he took
over the
entire analyst booth and it was fun at
first but
we'll get to it but so you know he says
you can play basketball you can play
football you can't play fighting
and i think it's very good for these
celebrities and other ex-athletes to
learn like
dog that that's what happens man yeah
like that's typically what will happen
if you get in there and look
paul uh jake paul is not a reef not a
real fighter
he's just the exactly that's the the
thing that the exactly he's not
technically he doesn't come from the sk
same background as a box
no but for the past three years he's
been training like a pro bono
he takes it more serious he has the his
he has the muscle memory like that check
hook
that's tough to teach dude that's muscle
that's him
of hours in the boxing gym when the guys
rush in to check hookah do to knock him
out
like that's no random punch that's not a
lucky shot like that's
technical [ __ ] dude so let me ask you
this and it goes back to those your two
minute rounds would you be
more you just said celebrities should
learn but that you were entertained with
that nate paul uh nate robinson and paul
fight
did you see my tweet am i he was like
yeah i saw that i said i said but i said
boxing heads are going to be real mad
when they realize
jake paul is the most entertaining boxer
on the card so is that a lie
no it wasn't a lie that was the truth
yeah people get so upset yeah there it
is right here was there actual like
so like logan paul shout out yeah
praised him
oh look at that i disagree i should have
had you commentate fam
yes and i'll probably i'll probably
here's my thing and i'll probably work
with logan and jake but the thing is is
shut up ah and i get what the the
analyst team was doing because they're
paying the check
i'm not the guy that's gonna suck him
off yeah i'm a tyson fan but he's not my
goat not even close
he's not my top five he's ever been i
love him he's just not
a lot of people that rick bowe lennox
lewis evander holyfield all better
careers
all better well you have george foreman
oh you're talking about him no i'm
talking
any like when you when you talk about
heavy weights yeah i'm going to talk
about heavy weights
he's not my top five because you didn't
even say linda's lewis you didn't get i
said lynch
yeah so that's your top five riddick bow
i mean
you muhammad ali george foreman i mean
frazier like to me they're all better
he's the most scary guy at the time yeah
but name the best dude he's beat spinx
come on man
come on you got a point when you look at
it he was so scary and we all grew up
with that being scared
when you look at tyson when you look at
level of competition any time he faced a
real dude
who he couldn't punk like evander
holyfield like riddick beau
he lost but also we got so it's like how
can that be your greatest of all time
well also like like when you talk about
grace all times in
any sport when you talk about you know
we talk about khabib when he fought
dudes who were
[ __ ] really good dominated him yeah
any time
dominated they tried bullying dominates
them you talk about goats jon jones
dude he had his share of dudes that were
like gus fin justice big just as
talented
dominated him dc dominated him
you you go through michael jordan as i
when he faced isaiah thomas or he faced
any of these dudes
dominates dude so if it's tough for me
for the argument of mike tyson being the
most dominant it's like
not really i think he's not the most
dominant he's the most scary the most
he's the most marketable yeah another
thing i think about tyson i know i'm
ranting right now but the thing you
gotta understand about tyson is
there was a narrative on him you gotta
remember he came out of prison for rape
right yeah there's a bad narrative on
him and then what happens
he goes away right he goes away there's
not much going on irish dude
yeah and then he loses two fights he
quit on the stool again can't be a goat
if you go on
he can't so he has back whatever so he
kind of goes away
so there's a dark cloud over him then
what happens he's putting the hangover
well he did the one-man play first or
the hangover uh no hang over first
okay and then we see him in that light
and you're like oh yeah [ __ ] yeah
tyson's dope man yeah then there's the
one-man show which i saw
which inspired me to start doing [ __ ] i
was like vegan dude i sure as [ __ ] do
it
that's not so then he does that right
and then gets in other movies and then
it's like here we are
he starts this the hotbox podcast which
is a big thing
yeah and then he has his weed business
like he's a smart dude
and i like tyson and it just gets him
as far as goats nah man and i agree with
him but would you take in the fact that
we'll get off it would you take another
paying attention you know i'm learning
so
when you train or die you would assume
he's the goat right
me yeah i don't know i guess no i'm
saying as far as the narrative
like just not being a being a casual oh
i thought it was ali
that's fair and heavyweight or or you're
saying overall overall yeah
i think like i would say i would say roy
jones the more dominant boxer of course
over a long period of time pound for
pound then mike tyson if roy jones would
have retired when he won the heavyweight
uh time he's too long he fought too long
thank you he didn't have to fight
uh uh antonio tarbert
you know antonio and he knocked him out
yeah he went back and found him for the
rematch yup he's there any excuses
tonight roy that's when
uh tarver helped man yeah welcome second
round let me ask you this
do you think when tyson trainer died and
they messed with him mentally because
that's all he's about
do you think like of course that's his
whole life that's all you know he took
you in
a lot of people will say when custom
model died when custom model had him he
was
like a machine i don't care copy that
you know what i'm saying it's like all
right
that's f and that sucks yeah and maybe
but those
the facts of the matter are when you
fought these guys who were your equal
you lost
so you can't beat the goat there's not
even are you i don't see an argument
no i don't know how someone would argue
that i don't know people do but i don't
floyd mayweather is the goat that's an
argument that yeah
fine sure not de la hoya how dare you
sorry i like protecting our names now
that's all i'm doing
floyd beat him yeah easy pernell
whitaker should be up there as well
but a hundred percent yeah yeah but
there's argument for floyd
50 no fought guys that were his equal
beat em dominate him
beat a young canelo you know like
there's some dope fights
put like this if you want to have the
gold argument you have to have you have
to bring something to the table you got
to beat your equal
yeah you can't just beat up guys lower
than you and knock them out and then
you're the goat
got it what about james tony i love
james tony he was 89
yeah story about james tony against the
ropes he was he was uh
i've worked with james tony's trainers
i've been around james tony because he
did ufc right
yeah but uh james tony when he was on
the national team
he did that with ufc that was awful why
would you say that you could have left
it was so bad i didn't know you did that
it was so embarrassing what was it yeah
one punch couture yeah he was a [ __ ]
really are you serious towards his ankle
picked him and choked him out and choked
him out that how fast was that fight
like what why did he do that fight
he was oh look at this [ __ ] no oh
no it came out of shape too oh
i was there for that fight you did did
you fight on the card or what year was
that remember what card was that
you see 118 it i fought on that card
oh pretty sure i thought maybe i thought
116.
edgar versus pennsylvania i know i
fought 116. oh my god and that was in uh
boston right was that the uh garden uh
co-main event oh frankie was the main
right yeah because it's title
um i got to see that submission
oh it's embarrassing yeah but uh james
tony uh
floyd was on his team uh de vera
williamson who's my tram partner for a
long time was on that national team
as far as talent goes james tony's the
most talented dude they've ever been
around
floyd to say this yep uh darrell
williamson say this the coach
the most talented dude they've ever been
around freak [ __ ] freak
so i'll tell you a story about james
tony james tony i
was boxing in burbank at this gym called
360.
and james when you have a fight he'll
show up when he want to show up
because that's not james tony but shane
tony will talk [ __ ] to you yeah
outside the ring and he doesn't even
know you so i was sparring this guy
named
uh uh terrell williams and we was in
there i think i was wondering
oh you know he's undefeated by the way
um and we was sparring
and james was like yo uh who was this
[ __ ] ass dude i swear i don't know
he's like who's this [ __ ] ass do with
these skinny legs like right there and i
look back at your point
and then i'm sorry
i'm listening story yeah yo i'm tired of
telling you yeah i'm sad
yeah sorry wasn't it
because his legs ain't nothing to brag
about exactly but then he goes he was
like yo but then i look
but i look over and it's james dude hit
me
and it's like oh [ __ ] so he's like yeah
beat his ass man his mama bit he kept
like that's how he kept
that's like trying to get in your head
exactly because you're a new guy and he
goes in there
and his sparring partners three guys he
doesn't even train talk [ __ ] to him like
that's his thing he's lazy he's lazy
so talented really and freddie roach
that's right are you still a fan of him
or after that we're like [ __ ] this dude
nah because i knew he was like i'm just
playing where you from we just thought
that's cool yeah he's good because that
would remind me of
uh the coach for northwestern who they
were undefeated they lost
uh saturday there's a coach there named
fitzpatrick i forget
pat fitzpatrick and he was a linebacker
for northwestern he was like
the best linebacker they've ever had he
was the team captain he was a stud
and when i was a kid i used to do the
university of colorado football
uh camps and it'd give you the college
experience so i was like i don't know
10. and you would stay you'd play
football daily and stay in the dorms
that night
and he was the coach there and he was a
big deal at the time he's like the man
and cause my coach gary barnett is his
coach gary brown at the university of
colorado football camp
so he brought him in because he was his
coach at northwestern and i was like oh
[ __ ] because i want to be a linebacker
i'm like oh there he is
and i remember the first day he's you
know he's having us do like these
foot drills on the ladder okay and i i
was you know i was i was a late bloomer
i had big feet i'd like i don't know so
acceleration 11 when i was like 10 you
know i had big feet
i had big feet and he looks down and
dude looks down and you know my plans go
there and i felt he looks at my fingers
feet are too big he'll never make it
what
what the [ __ ] and right in front of you
bro too much he goes feet are too big
you never make it
like why are you in the middle of your
drill oh yeah first day of camp i'm like
what the [ __ ] did you finish your drink
and then
we finished it and then we had there was
this stud there they were trying to
recruit at cu
and so he was talking to him and we were
he had to cover me i was playing tight
end
and i did this like up and out route and
starched him the quarterback threw the
ball over
and i just watched it go over and run
back and he goes no no points to me
in the because there was a black kid and
the kid would go he goes no no
james come over he goes let that scrub
get it i was like what the [ __ ] i was
damn
i cried in my dorm at night oh and i
will never forget
damn [ __ ] that damn shout out to
fitzpatrick
nah you know my first year cheer they
said i would never be good really
because too thick uh i just had no
coordination or anything like that
it's and then all a scale sudden i was
just like
yeah that's like what the [ __ ] is up i
was like oh okay i know
and then i just work i'm a hard worker
yeah
but that's the motivation that you need
yeah i'm like oh yeah
there's not a ton of people like you can
do this you're gonna make it
you know go online for good sake
no one's like way to go congrats
where are you going you don't want to
pay attention to it yeah
all those people online are fitzpatrick
feet are too big
okay cool dude made it far than you in
the nfl yeah very cool
very cool we was talking about uh you
know how people you know
try to survive through adversity a lot
of people not cut like that
yeah it's the playing instances it's
like with you your situation you could
have been gave up like no not it's not
for me so without shows look at you they
said you couldn't cheer
you know what i mean look at me they
said i have legs to grow i got it
out of the wheel the
in person so this camera is big and
personal
wait till we get the new cameras in
there i never heard that we got new
equipment coming
in person they did say that they was
like bro yeah because it's like it's
this angle right here which is by the
way if i just i don't know
dude no left i'm not sorry dude
i'm just saying this is the angle i
think it's just i'm trying to tell
people
but don't you think uh to go back to
don't you think nick robinson get
knocked out
knocked out is good for the sport yeah
because a lot of people start doing it's
like a celebrity
death match my favorite the guy jake
jake paul yeah he's so he he like
trained it's
hard hard and he's like 23 like 20
i want floyd him and logan paul are like
people want to give them [ __ ] they're
brothers they're youtubers but
as far as like work ethic goes they're
beasts they're monsters
they're not they're not famous by
mistake they're both very
talented and work their ass off i'm a
fan now you can say what you want
you know especially jake make some
stupid choices logan made some stupid
choices when they were young
about that real real young yeah yeah 23
and like 25.
they're like my age and younger yeah but
but this might imagine when you're
22 or 23 and you had 40 million in the
bank
like you've got to give those people a
little bit of leeway you gotta give them
the worst person and everyone who
critiques those two it's like dude what
were you doing at 22.
dude because these guys created a empire
yeah all right they don't need to do
anything else
like for jake paul like again or logan
paul dude
people can talk all the [ __ ] they want
about him but if you were set
financially they're set they knew where
the [ __ ] you know
a huge mansion in cabazencino
they do whatever they want they they
both choose to fight
yeah fight like that's a tough [ __ ]
goal that's how you know you love it
when you have all the millions in the
bank you're just fighting because you
love you fighting out of love
yeah uh it was a quote so what was
nate's deal what did he find out
poor check and that's the thing that's
funny that's what bothered that that
breaks my heart man yeah because
three-time dunk champion talented dude
now he's a meme damn and he was some
funny ass memes
jason just killed me all some [ __ ]
man
it was the nba logo but him laying down
first oh my god that one last night oh
my god
how about but how about he put a little
bit on himself because he did no
sparring
did work on no defense why is this
monster in jake paul
but then he's like puts it the nba on
his back he's like i'm doing this for
all the ballers out there
i'm gonna represent so all the nba gets
on his back what is that
curry yeah what is that girl's name see
facts i see no lies
that was so funny he didn't see him
after he got started
and then the nba making fun of him like
because that twitty put up you saw the
tweet no which one oh i read it out loud
right now
i can't believe i feel bad for him
because here's the thing his agent
i'm sure when they approach him like do
you want to fight jake paul and he's
like
i guess is this his first celebrity the
first person boxing experience ever oh
god so i'm sure when they approach them
and they go you hey you want to do this
fight to pay this amount of money goes
yeah what's the worst that could happen
this this guy this is the worst this guy
says tonight i'm fighting for my
brothers in the nba
athletes across the world and most
importantly my children
tyson jones hashtag whole lap play the
video
y'all you haven't seen it no after that
tweet you got to play it
yeah see they they they said but
she didn't even got to that point yeah
they should have stopped it the first
knock down yep
there's no reason he should go on yeah
you can tell he has no [ __ ] clue what
he's doing
he gets knocked down behind the ear it's
like just stop the fight there
he i started laughing oh my god i
started laughing that was clean that's a
clean hit dude that's a lot of times set
it up i want it i want jake paul
this is what's funny is when when they
went to the middle this is some gangster
[ __ ] there's two
comments over the weekend that made me
laugh jake paul
when they go to the middle and they go
all right talk to you guys in the locker
room let's touch him up
he goes it's judgment day he said that
yeah i was like oh hell no oh hold on
they said that like a bad guy up in the
90s when he said it
right right what like any or questions
all right let's have a clean fight
fellas he looks at him because it's
judgment day i was like damn oh
damn and that was my favorite and then
somebody uh
got the sound bite of baker mayfield you
know he's playing quarterback
and he's calling the play and the
defense shifts and in the middle of the
play goes that was cute boys
hike [ __ ] like throws a bomb yeah it
was dope
what did j what did baker make phil do
this yeah i think i think it's on uh
bar store was this like let this be this
sunday when they won
they beat i think jaguars
don't know uh baker mayfield he was the
number one uh draft pick from oklahoma
he's a high school trophy winner
and he made all these promises they
thought they were gonna be really dope
last year but they're finally good
this year nah i don't think he's on bars
too yeah it's on barstool it is
yup i got my uh morning routine usually
instagram barcelona or twitter no no uh
neither
the probably the actual website
he's calling the play and they shift
over and he goes that was cute boys
how did it hike like to do that in the
middle of a game
the most disrespectful trash talk i've
ever heard yo
that was [ __ ] cute
first yard game is noticing the same
thing
that was [ __ ] cute guys is he hey did
it take for
obj to get hurt for him to ball out for
real they're better without him because
they focus so much on him trying to get
him so many
you know balls now they're just better
yeah eight and three right
is that called stat padding no he's just
such
what tom brady did like like odell
beckham's such a monster
and like he demands certain number of
balls so they gotta work it into the
game plan
demand yeah i mean yeah it's okay oh he
can do that he's so good
he's an amazing player but they're
better without him yeah which is weird
to say
all right it's just shout out yeah shut
up we did a lot of boxing talk
but it was a boxing weekend a lot of
people watched like this isn't like
we're not breaking down earl spence
danny garcia we should like tyson yeah
right tyson versus uh roy's like a pop
culture
okay okay also i want to go back to your
point earlier about like younger
kids uh like not knowing who earl spence
and danny garcia
is right but it's not even that they
don't know who they are they're just not
interested it's not that heavy
well compared to like ufc
i think this is why i love ryan garcia
don't like his fighting style but i love
what he's doing for the sport
like he's bringing younger audience
audiences
inside that's stadium and they are
getting more like in tune to boxing
then they had these under cars it's like
oh this guy is nice and stuff like that
so it's a younger generation
you know and you know uh your boy um he
he might er what's his name
who without the young dude you're
talking about uh ryan garcia yeah ryan
garcia helped jake paul get ready for
this fight yep
they're boys they're tight he walked him
out he's a youtuber yeah he's a youtuber
who can i mean he's a legit boxer yeah
he just happens to be really big on
youtube
that's cool well i think that i think i
like that these social media guys and
also if you've been boxing all your life
social media is the way to go yeah you
know you're always you're gonna sort of
show i saw you post that
that's all that means shows are tight
yeah but
i mean yeah i would never go into
fighting never hell no
how much would they have to pay
chappelle for me to go into fighting
how much did nate robinson make gin
that's a great question yeah let's hear
that and then i'll answer that
i bet he made seven hundred thousand
jim would you fight anybody is that good
yeah i don't think how much
yeah yeah tell me that number a million
that's
it there you go nate robinson made 600.
wait six hundred dollars like flat well
you gotta pay your drink
how much did he make six six hundred
dollars each
that can't be right no that's two
different websites
yeah what that's crazy yeah no
from the back end though i've written so
once the pay-per-views come in they'll
get that
badoo jack made 180k yeah because
tyson's pro
this is somewhere chicken tyson
uh supposed to make 10 mil guarantee
joan's supposed to make three million
guaranteed
paul yeah i'm sure it has to be back and
that's weird 600
don't make sense no you know but maybe
they just put them on the card
like we get we'll give you a percentage
of the pay-per-view pay-per-view does
well you boys are gonna get paid
oh yeah yeah on the back end because
obviously oh
they got the money signed mm-hmm
how many pay-per-view buys oh it's not
out yet okay i'll keep checking though
look at this look at this pathetic look
at these drunk they like to my drunk
uncles and
in their underwear go up chance what's
up it looks like it looks like my two
uncles at a barbecue fight
i thought i thought soup was funny okay
what's your problem what's your name
you know the ufc tried him out on the
contender series yeah
and he got fired after like two episodes
why
because he kept making those kind of
jokes and it's not
like dude the contender series is like
young talent like
real [ __ ] and snoop doesn't know
fighting we all love snoopy there's no
[ __ ] fighting
so he's making fun of guys when they
lose they get knocked out you know and
you just can't have it
like it's not entertainment it's a
serious thing yo but it works for this
because it was it was entertainment
yeah that's why it worked i think him
and tyson had the same career you
remember when
snoop dogg went to rapid hardcore
hip-hop guy and we
his first like what we just started
acting with baby boy but
he starts training today but we started
seeing uh snoop in the playful light
when he got on that cooking show martha
stewart martial yeah
stoop commercials soup crossed over into
like regular like
celebrity like everyone knows snoop now
yeah everyone knows everything everyone
loves
with the high got his
yeah his podcast so yeah i think that's
i kind of like snoop i like
i love stupid she's one of my favorite
people okay well i'm just saying it was
it was it was only right for him to
commentate this fight you think
yeah 100 i think yeah i thought it was
going to go so this one especially
sports.com says
600 000 each which would make more sense
yes yeah but uh no that's not enough
that's not enough how much uh you got to
pay me a million i had someone ask me
how much you would count
i said well who would it be against oh
and then the other thing that's tough is
my background like i fought
professionally i was running the top but
she wasn't professional in boxing though
no which is a golden gloves yep but it
doesn't matter you got fans would you
fight
now i know we are big fans of the paul
brothers come on the show we love you
i'm too big for them
you're too big for them too big i'm
heavyweight you have to pick another
heavyweight guy oh wait they're not
i'd have to fight like terry crews what
with them
i fight the rock
i'm kind of intriguing
to slouch i would absolutely dismantle
the wrong listen he's on steroids
you don't think i'm
how many rounds how many rounds eight
two minute rounds okay two minute rounds
boxing yeah it has to be boxing i don't
know i got distance
i would beat the brother you would beat
the bricks where would you go what was
your biggest problem thank you
six four i've been elevating price six
four to
sixty that's right one of us is gonna
pass the drug test and his name
ain't the rock so he's six
five he ain't six five he's not no i've
been elevated with him he had
his heels done what's your game plan
talk to us yeah yeah cause i'm kind of
curious i mean i would
jab the piss out as moana knows for four
rounds and then light his ass up with
the right hand
do we have any like footage of rock just
like hitting the bag or something yeah
look at that picture
brendan i don't know yeah he's a bunch
he's jacked because since he put you in
that
like hole like clutch with the gloves on
he goes oh you're exhausted
yeah no he's swole there's no doubt
about it that man is swole
i see a rock sparring oh this is the
right oh this is anthony joshua oh yeah
okay he's showing something rocking me
real stiff
yeah oh
kevin hart good to see you brother
to see you all right good to see you
champion of the world big fight coming
up what's going to be pounding
right i want to cut you off
[Applause]
look i don't like it
what don't you like i don't i don't like
detective when i see something wrong
i can't keep it to myself
he's so so funny this is what you're
doing you don't watch this
what you need to do is focus on the foot
okay i didn't hear you say anything
about a foot we're in a fight i'm
stepping on your foot
[Laughter]
i don't know i saw that jab by the rock
brendan that's something that's a strong
knuckle right there
yeah oh come on man all right
it was great yeah look at rogan who's
rogan bringing down
oh my god mcgregor fight
oh anyone i want jake paul i told i told
rogan
you're not the same weight as him i
don't know i can meet him somewhere
yeah yeah jake jake paul
is saying this on bill about he has to
be careful because you know he called
out dylan dennis
like there's so many fights for him in
that youtube world
once he starts coming over to like our
lane starts dipping his stone real
fighting it could get dicey for him yeah
he fight a real dude look what his
brother doing calling out floyd
mayweather
i didn't like his posts you saw his
words he can't read yeah we can't run
hilarious
hilarious though but it was kind of i
love his improv comedy because you you
then w
dropped on mayweather he was like you're
not gonna get the w anyway i was like
that was hard but it's just this for
those boys
you know like they're laughing all the
way to the bank like he knows he can't
beat floyd
but laughing all the way to the bank but
how much money is it i told rogan i said
i can't wait to see tyson cameron
showing you gotta pretend that was a
legit fight
oh yeah pretend like that was like dude
i can't believe those body shots
yeah well i heard i heard tyson
deliberately like
took it easy on roy because you know
that's yeah it's a gentleman's bat like
that wasn't a real fight it was a
gentleman's bet
no hits to the face take it easy on you
don't want to call because
i feel like if ty's if it's a real fight
especially the condition tyson
he wouldn't took him out of the two
rounds probably two rounds i think so
with him you know tyson smoked weed
before i don't know
that's what i thought you know it's not
a real fight yeah well roy jones came in
oh
out of shape that's how you knew it
wasn't a real fight oh god he was
huffing him wait was he was he not
no chisel new hell no he had a preacher
body
not our preacher like a guy behind a
rock pastor yeah
he's just real soft oh god if you watch
if you watch his fights
like he used to be jack dude look at
that tell me the greatest ever do it
come on he looks exhausted damn
for a check
that's the bomber both these guys are
set on financially
they ain't doing this and isn't it weird
fighting's the only he's got a six-pack
look at that girl in the back yeah but
here's what's interesting is fighting's
the only sport where we'll entertain
this
like you'd never entertain joe namath or
joe montana
taking snaps for the niners like get the
[ __ ] out of here
true at 60. yeah fighting's the only
sport we're like yeah this is dope
we'll pay for this now you got me now
you got me intrigued
like would you watch magic johnson larry
bird
oh yeah one on one really yes
bro you know you stop how long are we
going to pretend
basketball is probably different come on
a one-on-one
magic job 60 year olds go at it it
doesn't matter they're still in shape
just [ __ ]
stop they're not like that okay doubt
they're gonna stop it dude their knees
that's the other thing oh dudes knees
are [ __ ] it doesn't matter
i like to remember them in their prime
dude i'm not trying to see this
washed out version i selling chin up
below the bed i said in
any other form of entertainment we'd
never put up with this
like can you imagine if steven spielberg
in 20 years had dementia
would you go see the movie with him with
dimension the camera's shaking and
[ __ ] freddie wrote style and it's
[ __ ] blurry
and he forgets
can i have a counter point the big the
big three with ice cube
has been
michael michael rapport you know i love
you that thing is a [ __ ]
i like that they got a four-point shot
get the [ __ ] out of my face
i'm not with it how long were pretend
that that's a real league how long do we
pretend i mean
how long do we pretend that three on
three is a real [ __ ] thing
people go to watch it i was about to say
and and before he died rp kobe
they were in talks getting kobe in the
big three he would have that's his life
you know why kobe wouldn't do it because
he's rich oh he did
notice the only people playing that are
people that don't have money look at my
goddamn guy
who who was they who's that uh chin
that's horse grant at 90 years old is it
again how long are we going to do that
yeah that's that ain't clyde director
that is that
that's not clyde drexler all right
that's not like drexer click on the
image
it is no the lead commissioner and clyde
drexler
uh couldn't be more excited oh that is
in power of the big three i think clyde
drexler oh you do give me uh image
searches
um what would it you that's not horace
grant though that's horse grant
[Music]
well maybe you made it no
now i'm kind of curious who is this guy
because i know
i'll look for you guys keep changing now
we getting so into it
but anyways that big three they had a
lot of people coming out at the stable
center
you got to pee okay
hey man you want to give the best gift
how much you give meat in your grandma's
mouth how about omaha steaks
perfectly aged 100 american grain
finished steaks
for the ultimate tenderness juiciness
flavor you see me posting all the time
all that grilled meat
is from omaha steaks omaha steaks
delivers everything you need
for a classic steakhouse dinner in the
comfort or your home
you get a freaking steakhouse dinner
right in your drawers
chilling at home every order is flash
frozen
vacuum sealed safely delivered in a
cooler with dry ice
it's super easy man you can put in your
freezer if it's too much meat you get it
out later with omaha steaks you can
avoid crowded grocery stores or
restaurants
uh they're easy meals they got so much
more steak and more
all backed by unconditional 100 money
back guarantee if you're not happy
deliver the perfect gift or send
yourself a gift man with omaha steaks
shipped directly to your doorstep that's
world's greatest stakes plus
premium meats easy meals everything you
need for a
great gift or stock up yourself all
right forget about gifts
give yourself the gift of meat get a
jump on the gift shopping with the omaha
steaks today all backed by 100
money back guaranteed that's how tasty
they are they trust it man
visit omahastakes.com type fighter in
the search bar to shop the best gourmet
gifts
of the season again that's
omahasteaks.com
type fighter into the search bar to shop
the best gourmet gifts of the season
chicken loose the baby diesel hayden
yeah
dog me my girl started uh
married at first sight season seven
we're on season seven
dallas dallas ooh in the city of city
well that's how it goes well i looked up
on uh top season
season five's number one season seven's
number two so we're on season seven
well my father-in-law we were trying to
so we got done with the tyson fight
and uh me and him were drinking and i
was like oh we're gonna start uh we're
gonna finish i think we're on season
nine i was like we're gonna finish
season nine and he's like of what i'm
like somebody at first sight so i give
him things like this is stupid
okay cool dude so we turned it on
we were tired so we went to bed he
stayed up to three in the morning binge
watching the rest of season
i couldn't get enough of it bro the show
is addicting
bro dude how about how about on season
seven
in three two one dude
there's this so it's three couples this
time there's this big black dude they
hook him up with this girl who's like
middle eastern her dad's middle eastern
her mom's black so she's pretty
yeah they hook this girl up you know how
on the honeymoon they always take new
mexico or costa rica or something like
that
they go to this is hilarious they go to
she seems so nice
they go to fly out customs takes her
down
won't let her leave the country they
have there's a warrant for arrest
and the produce the the production
staff's like we do
full extensive background checks because
that dude's like
like where's my wife man what the [ __ ]
responsible mexico and he's waiting at
the airport
they have to detain for like eight hours
and he's like what the [ __ ] what's going
on
finally the production staff gets the
warrant that was up for a rest
and apparently the warrant was filed a
day after they did all the background
checks and they're like we're so sorry
we do all the research this is on us
apparently the warrant was filed the day
after we did we did all the the checking
and all that stuff
she had three uh accounts out for
uh stocking and credit card fraud
so now he's just married to her so check
this out so then
she comes back to hotel and she's
talking to producers too she's like
oh i talked to them they let me go
because it was uh
it was a mistaken identity somebody you
know gave him my name it's not me
and so i was like that makes sense she
seems cool they go to bed that night
homeboy wakes up and mourning tears
face all puffy kind of looks like jay-z
but huge face
face all puffy's you could tell he's
been crying all night yeah and he's like
well
it's not all a lie she told me she did
she was in relationship with this guy
and all this [ __ ] and like what what's
she looking like so now they're trying
to figure it out go to season seven
made up for science they saw like both
of my shows combined and that great
this is so crazy and they're like damn
really gonna figure this out
kind of honest i love that kind of
sneaky pete mia valley
mia bally and tristan thompson not the
basketball player
oh okay
they were on there yeah oh [ __ ] chin
just showed me what happened what what
do you want to do
there she is though oh he doesn't look
like she's pretty yeah he looks like
jay-z
yeah oh she is pretty yeah she is
she does look like a little condom ah
[ __ ] they don't stay together oh
do you think they're gonna make that
thing i thought maybe they'd figure it
out
but i knew something was up because even
right when she came out my group goes i
don't trust i'm like
she's [ __ ] nice why don't you trust
her girls no
man but then you know when you know so
when they they
you know they're hanging out now i
pronounce you know husband
oh [ __ ] so they go now i pronounce you
man and wife you may kiss the bride
she went kiss him she wouldn't no she
gave him her cheek which has never
happened on the show before
oh what a [ __ ] yeah boyfriend crazy
right
that's so [ __ ] it's so good so we're
in the middle of that right now you give
me a chica the show is so hot
she's not bad though right yeah she
looks different she looks like different
different pictures she doesn't look like
a con artist
that's not a condom she looks like a
stalker no
she's stalking also i told my girl went
stocking taking one or two ways
she's the down-ass [ __ ] like maybe she
just loves this dude he doesn't want to
give it up
she looks so much better but i googled
uh stocking boy stocking gets a little
testy what do you mean what are you
showing up like you're stalking a person
so you're falling to work
falling at their house making uh
violence like
suggestions or death uh threats
definitely
that's and she did all that yeah that
would panic stalking is really
interesting because you can't get a
restraining order
because for you to get a restraining
order you have to tell them where you
live so they can stay away from it
so you have to get something else how
stupid are restraining orders
right it's like you can't is that like
work yeah how
they don't work so it's basically like
the policeman like you can't be in 600
feet of her and these stalkers like
cool okay only 600 sounds good yeah
that's easy but it's like that poor lady
in utah
she kept kept warning the the campus
somewhere in utah i forget this is like
a year ago yeah she kept
telling her parents told the campus
police it was she's a college student
and somewhere in utah
she's like this dude's crazy
ex-boyfriend won't leave me the [ __ ]
alone please do something
no one did anything you know killing him
homeboy stabbed her ended up killing her
was that in utah yeah that was utah i
thought okay i know no exactly looks
like
shane orders a show yeah
uh well i saw on on next friday great
but before
we away from here like you know man that
was restraining utah student killed what
does this say so it's not it doesn't
work
yep there she is youtube it kind of
gives you a list of where they would be
because you have to give them
a list of like where you work where you
live in order for them to stay away from
that area
otherwise you wouldn't know where to
stay like 500 feet away from
that's why it doesn't work for stalking
i think you have to get something else
for stalking rather than a
training like so she called the police
right and she was like this guy my
boyfriend is crazy
and that's like what do you want us to
do right so restraining order well i'm
gonna be here and be here
what's the next step yeah what's the
next step like what
if you're but if you're the the police
it's like what do you do like
all right he's not breaking the law so
it's like and then
we can't follow you around like we're
not your personal security yeah so
yeah i don't know it's something you
kind of have to wait until they do
something to get a restraining order
that's the thing that sucks is that a
bummer
it's not preventative it's kind of like
after the fact isn't that horrible like
you're a
female and like you have a stop yeah
like celebrities have stalkers and those
stalkers get arrested
all the time they break into their homes
they do crazy [ __ ]
taylor swift's dad got in a fight with
her stalker taylor swift was away from i
think
one of her homes i think either like
somewhere on the east coast new york or
something
he broke in when she was on the other
side of the country but her dad was
there
and uh they ended up getting in a fight
oh they threw hands they threw hands
listen it was a cbs show called stalkers
it was on cbs talk about like how they
go through it and how people like
literally crazy right and it's crazy
they had to cancel it wow i guess
because uh
the actress kept getting stuck oh [ __ ]
that makes sense though oh
it was a always a script it was a
scripted show yeah really yeah
well they're coming up with ideas off
base real [ __ ] yeah yeah and it was
great it was a great show
damn they took it all she was like nah i
want to be a part of this
yeah look at that yeah stockings by the
way bring that back
in two thousand that was a great series
look at that beautiful one oh maggie
all right yes that's my girl i love her
yeah like vietnamese or something
beautiful such a baddie
yeah this is a great uh dancing yeah
no but he was in csl he wasn't in stock
oh god oh they both got killed she was
getting started
well she was yeah look at her have you
ever had any like weird experiences of
like fans trying to follow you sure have
oof oh the lebron
the girl who told us that she uh the big
kids yeah she stalked me
oh yeah yeah show your tits no no i
didn't why do you keep
no i'm just saying that's her like is
she that's her is that her mo
that's her currency yeah she has a sugar
down she's like lebron
sucked on these
[Laughter]
i was like well which one so i can yeah
yeah which one that's great
that's prove it you know jay goes
that looks nice just some big ass
titties airbnb better be [ __ ] lit and
boise jay
can't wait man what are we doing what
are we doing i don't know we didn't
figure out because we're getting there a
day early so could be cold as [ __ ]
do you think so check the weather chin
in boise it's supposed to be like
freezing temperatures i think oh
i see it's fun though it's it's fun to
not live in that it's fun to go for a
day
yeah experience it and then fly back to
l.a what what
35 right now let's go to weather right
now
what's that [ __ ] like at night
as long as is there snow i think so
i know shoes to break yeah you know what
yeah like i don't even have
like oh let me see the shoes winter
clothes like i got timberlands i've been
waiting
oh no saturday's 41 and sunny that's not
too bad i'm too bad friday
night and sunny we're straight forty one
is yeah come on get shoes
i'm a [ __ ] desert rat it's going to
be freezing for you
yeah montana was so cold
oh my god different kind of cold so but
it was snowing though
not really not like the two days it was
but
it was just like at night there's no
snow we're in the hot tub it's like
you have icicles like off like freezing
to your head
it's not so cool leaving your sons like
daddy it's cold
yeah like we were out there shooting bow
and arrows and he's like damn ready to
go inside we're out there for five
minutes
yeah there's no way so what we're gonna
do in boise just chill like
make hot chocolate snuggles that's fine
we're gonna snuggle up i mean
i called chappelle just
what the hell did this god
thick ass i don't know that's my guy
jason i think he's shredded oh yeah he
said we've sold patrol
he's full of [ __ ] wait what are you
because i'm actually shredded yeah i
mean i think shredded is a different
dude
fans will write me and they'll be like
oh you're not as thick as they say you
are oh [ __ ]
that's what he said yeah they're called
stalkers
he brought that back stalking in a good
way no seriously what are we doing in
boys
any food spots the fans in boise i don't
know boise at all i know montana
i don't know boys yeah they eat potatoes
and boise yeah
there's a lot of meth um
state blue turf i don't know
if it was the summer we could go bike
riding you tired bro
we literally drove straight oh yeah yeah
yeah
five and a half yeah you woke up what
time i will give it uh
what time i went to bed i went to bed at
like close
close to four maybe four a.m yeah why
we had to drive back oh you you woke up
at 4am no no i don't wake up before i we
went to school
because as soon as we left the show you
drove last night yeah i'm sorry i
thought you said he left this morning
oh so you drove last night you got at
4am then what time you get up
i got a bed give me cause you text us
early huh
you look tired oh do i really yeah i'm
exhausted oh do i really
do i do have i looked at the way the
whole time you guys didn't even do my
makeup and [ __ ] what kind of [ __ ]
production is this yeah
you know what's weird is when your
parents haven't seen you know they're
like you look tired oh you mean i look
like [ __ ]
that's a nice way you look healthy
like 840 maybe chunky i woke up when you
texted us
oh [ __ ] we got to work damn yeah let's
go to some current events then
well here real quick it's a winter
wonderland festival you guys can go to
is that is that the is that the weekend
i know i would love that we're looking
for that in california
christmas
[Laughter]
we just need to find good food and we'll
handle the rest claus and paul sound
like a good
zoo yeah i like that well see for my son
this is
great to be great yeah trolley ride i
feel like this is a family
it's a hard time like this dope is it
yeah yeah we get all snow
philharmonic you keep saying snuggle i'm
just saying the nutcracker
shout out to friday at the next well
some fans just send us something to do
yeah
there's a bar some restaurant
all right drinking in the cold weather
will be fun yeah yeah nice
i want local boise whiskey that'd be
dope hopefully he has a good fireplace
oh why are we bringing him up okay sorry
michael b jordan has stated that he is
starting and only fans
and his only fans content is not going
to be nudes it's going to be
photos and videos of his beard and
mustache and he's eating stuff
and like [ __ ] gets in sounds [ __ ]
terrible and all of the proceeds will go
to
a barber school um this sounds like a
horrible idea
hey you know he's dating your girl
who's not laurie harvey let's not listen
that's it he brought her to thanksgiving
well here's the thing all up on them
titties
wait what does she look like again
don't bring it up get your boners out
she is
fine look at that there's one thing
listen you don't win sexist man of the
year and not have a dime like that
well that would hurt now she has a
history with some let's see who she
has every future uh trey song daddy
diddy p diddy son and now she goes to
michael b jordan because she wants
wholesome
you know what i'm saying he's a child
actor he's not you know he's not
dangerous like
no he ain't a bad boy yeah no he's
wholesome he just plays one on tv
i can tell you what's not wholesome and
they had to kill him on the wire
he deserved it god damn she got center
she oh look at her future had her the
best
he had her dressing nice look i'm a
future fan yeah future pull some hoes
well his catalog
got the chance give it up get it off
all right turn it off that's the story
was that the story that's my story
damn she's thick that's her mom is she
bought it up tim she's brought it up
she brought it up right right yeah you
are right yeah yeah that's how you know
you in like a different kind of class if
lori harvey you start dating laura
harvey
you made it like congratulations he had
to get sexy as man feel like she made it
they'll probably get married no no
what skill does she have obj she look at
her history you dated obj
she did everyone oh damn how old is she
she's 24
6 like 23. i think she's only 23 she's
in her prime and that's her
oh my god you're about 23. she's only
six years older than me
and she's she's dated all these people
already
yep look at her thanksgiving together
yeah are you kidding me yes bro i'm almo
i'm on my way just come
on how about futures lineup future has a
crazy life
baby mama blac chyna blac chyna okay she
got him tatted on her
oh yeah and then the same day he tweeted
that he's single he's single yeah that's
my stuff
like yep she does justin yeah that's
what she did that's
trey songz we forgot about trey i said
tray earlier yeah trey's a good looking
dude
with my boy that's a guy right there
what's in that night what's happening
jay follow him well you're crazy he's
the richest one she's dated
mm-hmm look who's who is that guy
memphis
some guy named memphis is he a writer
memphis rapper football oh no he's a
uh premier league player oh there you go
hey look at her list though look at her
list yeah
she's the catalog you're right she has a
cat thank you bro wow how can she not
that's insane i'm next malik's next
couple more episodes baby
malik just brings her today that's my
[Laughter]
oh gosh that's hilarious what else you
got jen
okay so this was sent in by ryan walsh i
believe we talked about this guy
before he's a bodybuilder from
kazakhstan we've talked about him before
yeah who is in a relationship with a sex
doll
and his whole backstory is that he met
her at a club
and he defended her from other men
trying to hit on her
and when he finally posted her on
instagram she got insecure about her
look so he took her to a plastic surgeon
where she got plastic surgery and she's
now working at
a as a waitress he just proposed a few
weeks ago and now
they are married she said yes that boy
is mentally ill i like her in the missy
elliott you're this [ __ ] [ __ ]
look at him and i'm just in a bathtub
with a [ __ ] toy
just wait uh
he's just trying to make some people do
this just to make like headlines yeah
nah
i mean what girl [ __ ] tired i see
nipples let me see
they have some plastic nipples so i
think we can show this they look pretty
good
[Music]
does that mean can you imagine being the
photographer who took these
oh yeah hold on all right
dude you sure you want to do this
he's a good-looking dude what is he
doing he's hairy too
okay man guy all right geico commercial
i'm fine already well you gotta do well
you're dating a doll homeboy
we gotta i don't trust dudes with nipple
rings yeah no never oh he has long
nipples too
you got the dog you know she's mentally
ill yeah
he does have big noses
do you get a nose job or something
scroll back so
i got it hey guys i feel better i made
my nose and teeth i made
my nose and teeth i want to thank you
for your support i appreciate your
support
send you my hugs and hot kisses
disgusting
he got a lot of followers 40 000
something nope i think well i think it's
47
000. yeah he's ill and that's the type
of guys that because he's thought
what is that that boy lost who's this
guy oh he's a gay man
home video of a joke this is a home
video for a joke song with my friends
oh uh he must be uh boy guess
i mean yeah he did wait is that a girl
that's a dude no i mean that's so i mean
dude if you're gay that's fine
you don't need to marry a doll to hide
it why is he dressed like his daughter
oh that boy
cheeked up girl let's not do this
get that boy a bike oh boy thick
that boy built like a black widow just
big ass
anyways big legs that boy
bodied up i'll give you a little bit oh
yeah he saw a boy
that boy gay gay he's got to be gay then
right 100 percent
i don't wipe my when i get a male 1 oh
my god he dressed like rakishi
he's into like freaky things uh yeah
yeah man ugh okay we can get off his
page now all right
all right let's get them down there down
there
this one or the other one yeah no that
one this dude's living his best life
yeah you gotta shade that [ __ ] yeah he's
quiet
he's a bodybuilder that's how my quads
gonna be in a couple of weeks i
guarantee
good for him man do your thing congrats
on the marriage
yeah to the happy couple yeah shout out
that's so s
i mean good dude's obviously got some
issues going on yeah love is tight
whatever way shape or form yeah whatever
yeah
uh yeah we already talked about this but
snoop dogg's commentary went viral on
twitter
there's a clip of him talking this one
here
[ __ ] is like two of my uncles find a
barbecue
two of my uncles fighting at the
barbecue
this [ __ ] like two of my uncles fighting
at the barbecue
okay you curse like snoop on that curse
oh
[ __ ] come on
it was entertaining for what that is
perfect for it yeah
why would he why he keep popping up
lebron james let's go
what did man say my aunt snoop dogg is
simply the greatest at whatever he does
man
swiss army knife steven a smith let me
read in his voice
are you listening to this man snoop dogg
call this fight
i don't know about the rest of y'all but
i'm loving this snoop dogg the most
entertaining part
of this fight i agree this is just
fantastic
he started he started singing when uh
nate ramsay got knocked out
he started what do you what did you say
you started singing some weird song
so everyone loves snoop you you say you
didn't like him i love steve
uh i like him for this okay i like him
in general
gabrielle union said i want to see him
commentate every sport
um all sporty look look what about
jl is the guy from insecure he goes all
sporting get it
how long will you even pretend that this
how long
i mean look the fans what look at his
face in
uh yeah i don't know if these are fans
also get off his nuts
like he did it all fight it was
entertaining for that part you know
oh if it was real fighting you wouldn't
be that into we didn't watch it so i'm
gonna watch it like later on
sunday and tomorrow you didn't watch it
on nah i was on stage oh [ __ ]
yeah he was literally on stage when it
was all going down yeah oh you guys
haven't had a chance to even sit down
and
watch it right now literally just came
back yeah yeah what else you got jen
here we go okay so speaking of kevin
hart i don't know why kevin hart sorry
i'm interrupted yet
i don't know why he entertains this so
he feels like he has to
talk to people about the backlash of his
special was this what happened little
baby said not no
no no
getting older dating boys and he was on
like his press drunken but they're doing
it all through zoom
he was on the clubhouse where the women
were talking about that
joke and he kind of joked around saying
like yeah these are just things i
observed and
i called three hoes to verify this is
whole like activity
i didn't call my daughter a hoe i'm
saying what she's doing is hoe-like
and a bunch of people took issue with
this and started saying that it's a
black
issue and he doesn't like black women
and this and that
and so he ended up going onto social
media onto his instagram page
and made like a minute long video
defending himself
let me is i don't get why he does this
i hate every time he apology had a hat
on
how long are we going to pretend how
long are we going to brendan has could
talk to the side
he's always like this
i mean it's better than the ti where he
just placed it on his hat side
head side every issue is an apology or
like always he's like trying to
tell you why he did it he's always liked
us
all right guys look we gotta stop all
right stop with the false narrative
it's a false narrative of being created
if you were in the clubhouse and part of
the conversation
this wasn't about black women it wasn't
about
me going against black stop a question
was asked about
the joke about my daughter and and me
referencing my daughter having whole
like activity
i have an answer to it here's what it is
guys when i called my daughter
hoe i'm saying what she did this whole
like activity
i called three former hoes that i knew
and asked them
we had a conversation about it a good
back and forth there was never a black
woman and black man back never so stop
with that false narrative first and
foremost
also understand guys there is no other
way to market or promote because we're
in a pandemic
i can't go and do the talk shows that i
once did or go out and do the public
stunts i have no other way to market and
promote
except to go viral i have to create
conversations
generate back and forth that's the
marketing and promotion
attached to my now special
it's common sense here guys marketing
promotion
that's why i was in clubhouse marketing
promotion
conversation hence it leads to streams
so if you haven't seen it go see it zero
[ __ ] getting streaming now
but stop with the false narratives and
the clickbait
and the back and forth there was no
comparison to barack and oprah the [ __ ]
that i'm seeing stop
stop it stop it
false narrative marketing promotion
conversation
zero thoughts given on netflix what
shows are you referring to
clubhouse what is that it's a uh radio
show
oh got it oh he said it on the radio
show yeah he was doing an
interview basically promoting his
special he's doing a bunch of them
and this is the one that gained traction
because yeah uh
that's a show with primary primarily
just women
got it okay yeah it is crazy how people
just
take something you [ __ ] saying you
can't say something like joking they
think they know exactly what the [ __ ]
you mean it's like
as a comic yeah it's not i mean you
could say whatever that bit was
hilarious man i loved it
i loved it because i like jason and dad
and i like i was like well [ __ ] homer i
like him too it was so
funny man i love it you watch the
special cat it's good it's good i liked
it
i loved it i heard some people didn't
like it
that's that's how it goes right it's the
only some people don't like the drake
song or the weekend song you know it's
just it's no different oh yeah wait
speaking of drake
that song he did on lil wayne dedication
uh
i haven't heard it oh you guys get fired
drake don't miss
yeah ever ever and it's a flow that he
hasn't done in a while there's no
ceilings
how about my son uh we're hiking his dad
can't play that song i'm like what song
cause he gets
his fierce song was the baby you know
the
lamborghini in the cop car oh rockstar
yeah yeah he loves that song
and as his new one he goes uh go go to
sleep we gotta stay up and i'm like
what the [ __ ] i'm like why are you just
don't go to sleep guys stay up dad i'm
like
i don't know what song you're talking
about so then i typed in the lyrics
skywalker made that
miguel song skywalker that's it go to
sleep that's a good taste of music yeah
that's an awesome song yeah that's a
whole oh yeah right yeah yeah
i'm thinking like whatever i don't know
where he heard it
a youtube video probably a tick tock
tick tock
tick tock you're so so adorable i was
like do you like bts he was like
he lit up when i asked him you like bts
didn't they have like yes singing the
night i just want to say it's a
domination
uh christmas special yeah oh hello oh
wow yes bunch of other people singing
for tonight for christmas also i want to
ask you this chin it's another asian
group that's circulating um
around it was like girls females no they
look like girls
but it was two dudes like it was last
night like it was like on what like they
were dancing
and oh [ __ ] but the biggest girl group
right now that's k-pop is
uh black pink yeah black pink black
oh you're in that k-pop world yup damn
he knows what's up yeah they're big hold
on
i'm sorry y'all continue i'm gonna find
it all right um this is what
jay jay shobb brought up takashi six
nine
yeah there's video of them getting into
this
six nine look like a straight g right
here watch out he talked with the money
in his hand this [ __ ] was crazy
let me see here we go we wait
we trade way here
look at my man look at it look how is he
still in the club just living
just wait first of all where's this club
in atlanta
look at you look straight gangsta
what is that music i don't know it's
gunshots
it's like king von i guess rp so he's
throwing apparently throwing money at
jevonte
that's 50 right does takashi
and i know what would happen davis went
over there
huh no no they they just be they it was
nothing at all
javonte davis would knock his face i
mean
exactly but i mean if he thought the
nate robinson knockout was bad
if javonte davis walked over there for
real yeah damn why is he talking [ __ ] to
jealousy
i think javonte was talking [ __ ] to him
because javonte is a street dude yeah so
anyone who's a street dude can't stand
six nine because
he called him snitch k what does snitch
k mean oh like
so at the case snitch killer oh
like they put a k behind anything killer
gotcha
thank you no problem i needed to get hit
for just being around the [ __ ]
but who am i
yeah wow either way it's just a whole
bunch of
nothing oh there it is namely after king
vine
i thought i heard that song there were
moments he popped up yeah
all right all right well sheesh well
he's just throwing up money yeah but
honestly though we talked about like how
this
is not really like that that also his
baby mom came out after this video
and wrote some mean stuff and like just
like exposing him he's a shitty dad
yeah shitty dad yeah what'd she say
about him uh go to the shade room real
quick
the shader yeah mean we was driving home
i was like let me just see haven't been
on here in a minute
the shade room channel um go down scroll
up wait hold on wait go back who's that
third one right there with the titties
the third one yeah right here let me see
who that is no who's the far left one i
think they asked kim kardashian
yeah eliza raine oh future baby mom of
course you're gonna be one of them
how many baby mamas does he have we got
like nine six
six on my back that's expensive i go
down very expensive
you sure wasn't on the no no no i should
no no no i'm trying i'm just going
unless i saw that's like go down
what was it go down because they're
gonna show like the video six nine i'm
getting to it and then next the
following
the next post is her talking crazy go
down go down
no way it's this far down yeah it's
right here right here that's it right
there this one here
uh go up up which one no it's not no
it's not i apologize
hold on go now come on wait no problem
i was i swear my baby father yeah told
you look
she released all his info the second
slot
it's alive here i haven't spoke
back on him for a while when i speak on
him i speak on the situations that were
bad
refrain from feeling any type away from
all abusive hurtful
[ __ ] he did to me [ __ ] my daughter
witness because of you but what am i
gonna do is
have you refer to our daughters as that
little girl like she doesn't mean
nothing
all you do is cap about our daughter to
these [ __ ] little kids on ig
because honestly those are the only
people that are left calling us
fans [ __ ]
confuse miserable drag and distract me
all over this [ __ ] fine
but to address our daughters that little
girl and literally treat her like
nothing over the phone to my mom's
so he basically called his daughter so
he makes you know he take
posts about his family and she's saying
like you just
you you capping on the instagram all
right oh you referred to my girl
you for our daughter as that little girl
you don't see any money
yeah and that's the clip of uh she just
saw that him while in throwing money
i'm saying he ain't [ __ ] yeah and he
throwing money in the club and she's
like man
can i have some money for my daughter
damn he look gangster though right this
is in miami
oh miami they have the clubs open there
i guess so i know right now
they said six nine go troll his way into
the car they ain't lying
javonte ain't the one to mess with yeah
what do you say all the guys
yeah at least he's not going to shoot
you i know but he'll knock you to hell
easy try fighting
but listen he's paying for his security
you're not going to get close to yeah
you know but this big but chevante got
he got girls around him as well because
this one
yeah shout out to my man man i gotta
call him what else you got all right
and i gotta pee again i've been drinking
so much what i know i'm sorry
because if you're not eating solid the
water just
oh [ __ ] that reminds me
[Music]
all right yeah so these are from uh
carlos de la garza he's a grammy
award-winning
engineer producer he's my mentor he's
the one that taught me how to do
engineering
these are his signature sticks i want to
see if you can actually play
something remember you said you could do
something exactly
the people just like you know all right
what do you want me to play anything
remember you said you could play but
just the way you're holding them already
like oh [ __ ] you know what's up bro
y'all really don't believe me bro but
alright it's okay what huh i'll be
playing it man let me see
it's been a long it's been a while
the way he's holding him though
he's messing around he knows how to play
he does not have
that really see i don't know i don't
know the technique of holding it
uh you know but uh
you know i i could probably do a little
something do a little something
let's see i don't know if i can hold it
i got you go ahead
[Music]
you actually held it right like this too
yeah
no i know i was in a band
[Music]
whoa okay this is in india yeah this is
a tiger chasing a guy in a village
and then actually all this he was able
to get away he fell down a 15-foot cliff
but then the tiger eventually ran off
right after they fell
and i guess the the tiger escaped one of
those like you know natural whatever
habitat places with that they actually
have they built for them so escape that
watch this video dog this [ __ ] is
[ __ ] so this is the first video
so that's the first video but this is
the full one
[Applause]
it's not it's a wildlife park that
escaped
is it hard to see for you guys but the
tiger the tiger leaves him alone yeah
yeah once he fell
because the tiger ate [ __ ] was like yeah
[ __ ] he almost grabs him right there
and tiger runs up right there
and then that dude he finally gets up
[Applause]
you can tell he's messed up but he's
alive
yeah yeah that tiger look at the whole
squad
look how fast that tiger is so it looks
like he even grabbed him a little bit
in the mid area and it sucks because
like once a tiger
like those big cats once they're locked
on one of those [ __ ]
that's this one yeah it's staying on
that he's lucky that that thing was
there
otherwise that if that was just a kept
going grass field it was just regular
yeah
landing screwed it's been set idra's
elbow was mad
been cool
oh um that's crazy [ __ ] insane
i was shocked i didn't realize the
horses could be this big but check this
out oh
god it's got to be a clydesdale yeah my
little pony goo
got that dick on him okay well you can
see it
how can you see it what do you mean
i'm mad i look
now can you ride that yeah i mean
clydesdales i'm sure the people you can
read
um i wouldn't why you said it like that
yeah
you're right you can ride that big ass
thing
so we've seen this video already but
there's an actual close-up on this whale
swallowing the people in the kayak
let me see where it goes check this out
oh look at that how close it got
what a nightmare that scared a piss out
of me dude
that was insane oh no
this is oh this is them recording it
yeah there's like different angles too
that was the first single we saw but
then the close-up is the crazy one
oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
you gotta wait till they blow that
little thing out that's what dora did
to him dory dory
wait so i wonder what he was trying to
get the bait fish just a little baby
they just go open their big mouth and
see
fish like in the mountains yeah they'll
usually follow a school of fish
yeah that was super close it was
probably more pissed off that the
[ __ ] kayak was in the way yeah
[ __ ] i haven't shown you guys
this clip already i'm not sure if i did
okay we see a lot of animal clips this
is how cool yeah this is how cool is
this for real
this is a bird that's fishing using bait
oh no sound but see there's big fish
that come in he's not gonna be able to
eat it he's all no
no no no fellas keep it moving keep it
moving yeah get your thick ass
he has a little piece of bread whatever
smart man
and watch this
oh god how insane is that that's pretty
dope
yeah that's that ass that's so chin like
this
that's the uh that's the green heron
that's the word that did that yeah that
was cool
uh i was gonna play that one but not new
oh so this is a sad one
the bomber yeah the founder ceo of
zappos shoes you know zappos.com he like
revolutionized the online bike huh
no it's just it's an online store for
shoes zappos zappos
he suddenly died in a fire at his
friend's house
he's a multi-millionaire and it just
seems very weird like especially this
day and age to die in a fire in a house
but this is what happened so far we
don't know any more details
46 years old rrp man what does he mean
zappos if you look up like gold for like
a billion dollars yeah it's
i think amazon bought them out something
like that it was one of the biggest
uh shoe online shoe sales websites yeah
yeah yeah yeah
like shoes not like the shoes yeah we
get just like yeah everything
all the shoes that you get like dsw yeah
you got it
wow mm-hmm and a fire and a fire and a
house fire at his friend's house
it was during a family event too i think
do you think it was a setup
i mean obviously yeah i'm thinking when
i when i first read this i'm like
how do you die in a house fire
especially if you're in a really nice
house too you're a smart dude too
yeah come on man and it seems like it i
don't know but who knows
how do you say his last name sue i think
say
what do you say the chinese the hsi
imagine chinese
chinese or taiwanese super smart guy
tony hey
yeah very beloved by his company yes all
the workers
i thought the answer was a rest in peace
uh i saw this i thought it was cool
this guy in a wheelchair legs his mouth
felt like that comment wasn't even
needed
check that out damn oh wow downhill
skating
yeah in a wheelchair stop though how do
you stop hitting a wheelchair i'm sure
it's built a certain way
you know with specs so he can actually
stop i wonder if it's an electric board
where you have a remote
too so yeah it could be that yeah that
could be
damn he's flying yeah that's so scary
what kind of shoes he having
yeah i'm scared what kind of shoes
that's giving me like a rush so that's
cool
how about chappelle as soon as we get
off uh our friday show we get in late we
drive five hours
first thing he does in the morning is go
skate with his friends yeah
skate his life yeah skate his life dog
all right we do that [ __ ] say less oh is
that another video
yelling that's a dude this guy is
illinois yeah evan mullen you mean to
him too or whatever
wait what is this gonna treat him like
[ __ ] that's just him
appearing on ellen that six days ago i
guess oh wait he's the new ellen
no no no he's the guy that was on the
wheelchair like he's inspirational so he
appeared on no one you you haven't got a
lot of sleep
i got a lot of sleep i'm out of it yeah
i know you're hilarious all right
that's good all right cool well well you
know we're with this at least you guys
made it we made it through this boise
this saturday
let us know what to do what's fun out
there boise idaho
this saturday one show one night only
saturday night december 5th
me and the boys will all be out there
the west palm beach palm beach improv
florida
uh december 31st through january 2nd
we bring in uh 221 the right way with
us the thick boys we will be out there
tickets at tfatkay.com thick boy merch
available now thick boy tie-dye hoodies
tie-dye tees we have short sleeve
hoodies we got thick girl uh
leggings thick girl shorts we got the
short sleeve hoodies we got it all
the new hats which i'm obsessed with the
thick boy bike club patch hats
thickboy.com get them boom is that it
kids
yeah that's it oh i'm sorry i couldn't
sell any merch at 10p
they wouldn't let me bob right that [ __ ]
happens well that's what our line is for
yeah yep we're out thank you